ja meine damen und herren 1999 haben wir
es erlebt inzwischen nicht in dieser
drastischen form aber durch reale
einsätze immer wieder sind 60 bis 80
alarm start die von der aktiven
komponente der österreichischen luftraum
überwachung pro jahr durchgeführt werden
und heute erleben wir sie in kürze live
hier im einsatzraum zur musikalischen
einstimmung für die beiden eurofighter
die heute hier überfliegen werden wie
gesagt die alarmrotte der
luftraumüberwachung in bewaffneten
zustand sie werden für die ehrengäste
jetzt gesprochen von ihnen aus gesehen
aus richtung links kommen dass es westen
von der bahngeleise richtung und werden
dann richtung osten abfliegen
zur musikalischen einstimmung hören wir
davor den fliegermarsch von dostal herr
kapellmeister bitteschön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja meine damen und herren in wenigen
sekunden erwarten wir sie hier warum
graz in der sie sich zu beginn des
fliegermarsch befunden haben hier im
anflug und sie werden wie bereits
erwähnt aus dem bereich der bahngleise
in einem langsamen überflug richtung
osten abfliegen
[Musik]
frau bundesminister landeshauptmann
damals wie heute wir schützen österreich
es erklingt nun die heinz zeller fanfare
komponiert und dirigiert von unserem
militär kapellmeister oberst magister
doktor hannes lackner
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit der musikalischen darbietung der
heinz zeller fanfare ist unser
geschätzter herr militärkommandant
brigadier magister heinz zeller
gefordert und gebeten seine begrüßung
durchzuführen um unsere herren und
festgäste offiziell willkommen zu heißen
hoch werte frau bundesministerin hoch
geschätzt bei der landeshauptmann
sehr geehrter herr general sehr geehrten
und festgäste meine damen und herren als
militär kann man von steiermark biete
ich zunächst allen einen respektvollen
und herzlichen gruß allen ihren gästen
den abordnungen sowie besonders den zeit
zeugen die heute zum festakt anlässlich
des 30 jahrestages des beginns des
sicherungseinsatz es hier nach spielfeld
gekommen sind
es freut mich zu diesem würdigen anlass
eine so große anzahl an hohen und
höchsten repräsentanten des öffentlichen
lebens von heute und auch von 1991
begrüßen zu dürfen
gestatten sie mir endlich einige wenige
hervorzuheben
an der spitze begrüße ich unsere vom
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
klaudia tanner herzlich willkommen frau
bundesministerin
ein respektvoller groß gilt dem
landeshauptmann von steiermark hermann
schützenhöfer herzlich willkommen
ich grüße herzlich den kommandanten der
streitkräfte generalleutnant magister
franz reißner von den gesetzgebenden
körperschaften begrüße ich herzlich den
herrn abgeordneten zum nationalrat
bürgermeister jörg im schnabel für die
anwesenden behördenleiter begrüße ich
den landespolizeidirektor von steiermark
hof grad magister gärtner und
bezirkshauptmann hofrat dr manfred walch
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
für alle anwesenden bürgermeister und
gemeindevertreter grüße ich denke gerne
songs bürgermeister von strass oberst in
ruhe
reinhold höflich
[Applaus]
es gab der hohen geistlichkeit an der
spitze militärpfarrer man privat gramm
und militär kaplan johannes freitag
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
stellvertretend für alle anwesenden
komponenten und dienststellenleiter
begrüße ich sozusagen den hausherren
hier den koalitionskandidaten von strass
und komponenten des jäger button 70
oberstleutnant georg pilz unsere
partnerschaftliche groß gilt den
behördlichen und freiwilligen
einsatzorganisationen ich grüße sie herr
bezirkspolizeikommandant oberstleutnant
christian zuhörer oberstleutnant
ingenieur herbert karner und
oberstleutnant helmut zerrer respektvoll
willkommensgrüßen bitte ich allen
verantwortungsträgern und teilnehmern im
sicherungseinsatz 1991 die ich in so
großer anzahl hier begrüßen darf
natürlich darf ich zwei hervorheben von
militärischer seite den damaligen chef
des stabes militärkommando steiermark
herren generalmajor in ruhe
heinrich winkelmann
und den ehemaligen bezirkshauptmann
hofrat dr johann saiger das
österreichische bundesheer gedenkt heute
des 30 jahrestages des sicherungseinsatz
1991 mit zwei veranstaltungen eine irin
spielfeld straße und die andere schon
heute vormittag in kempten
ich möchte nicht im detail auf die
historischen ereignisse eingehen aber
gestatten sie mir zu bemerken dass im
jahr 1991 und in den jahren der
konkreten einsatz vorbereitungen der
opfer bearbeitungen you eine
erfolgsgeschichte des bundesheeres
geschrieben wurde
die verfahren zur vorbereitung eines
militärischen einsatzes waren stimmig
und die militärische landesverteidigung
in der umfassenden landesverteidigung
sehr gut eingebettet com rannten stäbe
und gruppen durften auf eine positive
auftragserfüllung vertrauen
auch heute kann sich die bevölkerung auf
das österreichische bundesheer verlassen
wenn es darum geht schutz und hilfe zu
gewährleisten
das zeigen wir gerade jetzt während des
laufenden sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz es hier an der
staatsgrenze und allen einsätzen zur
bewältigung der korona pandemie ich
danke nochmals allen für kommern und
wünsche alles gute
ein herzliches steirisches glück auf
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren geschuldeter
hitze haben wir einige musikalische
programmpunkte gestrichen um die
veranstaltung zeitlich im rahmen zu
halten so sei es mir gestattet
ohne musikalische einleitung dich herr
bürgermeister lieber herr oberst als
bürgermeister der gemeinde straße in
steiermark und eine grußbotschaft zu
bitten
ich bedanke mich gleich in diesem
zusammenhang ganz offiziell für alle
infrastrukturellen und sonstigen
unterstützungsleistungen die uns die
gemeinde zur durchführung dieser
veranstaltung wieder einmal so großzügig
gewährt hat dank der bürgermeister
[Applaus]
geschätzte frau bundesministerin sehr
geehrter herr landeshauptmann meine sehr
geehrter herr general herr
militärkommandant geschätzte hohe
repräsentanten der einsatzkräfte und der
politik brauche ich als bürgermeister
und sogar die sonst gemeindestraße darf
sie aus aller herzlichste zu dieser
gedenkfeier für das jahr 1991 willkommen
heißen
die marktgemeinde straße ist schon immer
eine grenzgemeinde gewesen wenn ich sage
immer dann stimmt das nicht ganz seit
etwas mehr als 100 jahren wurde die
steiermark damals nach dem ersten
weltkrieg in zwei teile zerrissen und
die untersteiermark abgetrennt seit 100
jahren wie gesagt ist hier eine grenze
und wir hatten schon mehrere bewaffnete
auseinandersetzungen die hier die grenz
bevölkerung erleben musste eine davon
war 1991 selbst durfte damals im stab
des landes stamm regiments 53 als
hauptmann meinen dienst versehen und
darf vielleicht ganz kurz zwei episoden
aus diesem einsatz
die mich auch sehr nachhaltig in meiner
militärischen lang geprägt haben
bekanntgeben
das erste war als weitere drei kompanien
dem land herrscht allgemein 353
unterstellt wurden
meiner erinnerung nach einer aus tirol
aus kärnten und eine aus
niederösterreich war ich damals als
wirtschafts oder logistik offizier dafür
verantwortlich die entsprechende
unterkunft zur verfügung zu stellen
die räumlichkeiten waren schnell
gefunden
wenn wir im rahmen des operationssaals
jugoslawien das bestens vorbereitet
gehabt haben und wir nur aus den ordnern
heraus die daten raus nehmen müssten
es war aber notwendig das entsprechende
gerät dazu das heißt feldbetten und
andere utensilien aufzutreiben um den
soldaten eine halbwegs vernünftige
unterkunft zu gewährleisten um etwa 7
uhr halb acht uhr am abend habe ich
damals noch per telefon
es hat noch kein e mail keinen
elektronischen akt und keine jets
gegeben mit telefon einen antrag
gestellt das ministerium damals ist das
auch möglich gewesen den direkten
kontakt hat zu finden um zuweisung von
der entsprechenden anzahl dieser
utensilien und zu meiner überraschung
waren diese geräte bereits um 3 uhr in
der früh nächsten tagen nach wenigen
stunden hier bei uns vor ort und konnten
verwendet werden
was will ich damit sagen es war für mich
damals äusserst motivierend zu sehen
dass wenn der sogenannte hut brennt auch
alle ebenen von der untersten bis zur
oberen ministerium bestens zusammen
arbeiten und gut funktionieren und eine
zweite episode noch wir hatten damals
von unserem kommandanten oberstleutnant
josef kolb und bekamen als stabsoffizier
den auftrag immer wieder so genannte
motivation fahrten zu machen hinaus sind
die stützpunkte zu den vorderen
stellungen und zum einen zu erfahren wo
den soldaten der schuh drückt und zum
anderen auf den soldaten entsprechend
mut zuzusprechen
ich habe dort unglaubliches erlebt ich
habe dort hervorragende kadersoldaten
erlebt wie engagiert an ihre arbeit
gegangen sind und ich habe dort wirklich
entschlossene rekruten gesehen die
teilweise erst sehr kurz in der
ausbildung standen entschlossene
rekruten gesehen die wirklich bereit
waren ihr land die republik österreich
mit der waffe zur verteidigung und auch
das hat mir persönlich einen ungeheuren
motivationsschub gegeben für meine
weitere laufbahn als offizier eine
anmerkung sei mehr nach gestattet
nicht das glück war unsere stärkste
waffe wie es manches mal moniert wurde
nein meine damen und herren wir hatten
stärker den waffen wir hatten panzer
werden kampfflugzeuge werden
maschinengewehren und werden
sturmgewehre und wir hatten
und das ist glaube ich das entscheidende
wir hatten hoch motivierte gut
ausgebildete offiziere und
unteroffiziere dieses lag die sich lange
auf diesen operation vorbereitet haben
und bestens ausgebildet werden und wir
hatten wirklich hoch motivierte und
entschlossene rekruten und dass meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren war das
glück und deswegen möchte ich als
bürgermeister das kann sonst
bürgermeister hier und heute diesen
eingesetzten soldaten und natürlich auch
allen anderen einsatzkräften den dank im
namen unserer bevölkerung aussprechen
und sage noch einmal danke für euren
einsatz 1991
vielen herzlichen dank nova ist auch für
deine zeit zeugen erinnerungen die es
uns leichter ermöglichen ein bisschen in
der geschichte zurück zu blenden
bevor ich mehr zu unserem heutigen zeit
zeugen gleichzeitig würdigenden
generalmajor in ruhe was die ereignisse
1991 betrifft sagen darf will ich zuerst
gemeinsam mit ihnen die heinrich
winkelmeier fanfare hören
sie wurde anlässlich des 50 geburtstages
von generalmajor in ruhe heinrich
winkelmeier komponiert damals auch
uraufgeführt und heute von unserem
militärmusik steiermark zum besten
gegeben
[Musik]
das war so er war eine respektperson
einzigen ausmaßes für uns und ich will
nun bevor der generalmajor die
militärhistorische würdigung hierdurch
findet eine ganz kurze episode ihnen
erzählen es war der 28 juni
ich war kompaniekommandant der kaserne
in fehring von einer ausbildungskompanie
aus dem jänner et jene eindrücke - auf
der einen seite ammann dritte platz
haben die soldaten gewartet es war ja
abrüstungs tag damit sich die soldaten
nicht sehen haben wir auf der anderen
seite des gebäudes eine alarm company
formiert am sportplatz wenn es war bis
zur letzten sekunde nicht bekannt werden
die soldaten nun entlassen oder gänse in
den einsatz
und während wir diese alarm company im
sportplatz formierten ich erinnere mich
so gut drei offiziere waren anwesend da
überflog uns ein jugoslawischer
kampfflugzeug im tiefflug über diesen
sportplatz alle haben bestaunt gebannt
zum himmel geblickt und dann war sie weg
und dann sagten wir und jetzt horse life
flieger erkennst du mich da wussten wir
erstmals was es wirklich wert war
diese ganzen broschüren flieger
erkennungsdienst die wir in der
ausbildung verwendet hatten hier
umzusetzen
und es war uns ein bisschen
hochnotpeinlich bei der meldung an das
vorgesetzte commander bloß sagen zu
können
feindliche luftraumverletzungen über die
garnison fehring ein feindliches
kampfflugzeug eindeutig als feind
identifiziert hat soeben die kaserne
überflogen und irgendwie war ich
vorbereitet eine rüge eine kritik von
unserem herrn oberstleutnant zu erhalten
weil man eine qualifiziertere meldung
von einem offizier warte was hat
oberstleutnant winkelmeier damals gesagt
schon gut christian ich denke die
gleiche maschine ist vor fünf minuten
über graz geflogen
das möchte ich ihnen nur hier
darstellung um ein bisschen unseren zeit
zeugen wenn ich nun hier her bieten darf
generalmajor in ruhe heinrich
winkelmeier in seiner führungsaufgabe
einzuschätzen
sehr geehrte frau ministerin
herr landeshauptmann material leutnant
ein regio card bürgermeister
eine erde offizieren unterversichert
zivildienst dass soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheeres meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren heißt es heute
heiß war es damals
kritische punkte verfassung artikel 79
absatz 1 steht dem österreichischen
bundesheer obliegt die militärische
landesverteidigung
es ist nach den grundsätzen heißen
milizsystems einzurichten
heute vor 30 jahren stand dieses
österreichische bundesheer der zweiten
republik vor seinem ersten und bis dato
einzigen echten militärischen einsatz an
der staatsgrenze wenige tage zuvor haben
slowene und grazie und hauptstädten
große unabhängigkeit feiern abgehalten
und die bälle gerade zentralmacht hat
die jugoslawische volksarmee jva diese
abgekürzt haben uns genannt wurde in
marsch gesetzt um diese
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen mit
militärischer gewalt zu beenden
jugoslawische jagdbomber haben unter
verletzung des europäischen luftraumes
ziele angegriffen
eine lkw blockade südlich von shanti mit
boden luft boden raketen und
kampfpanzern schützenpanzer der jva sind
an die grenze den grenzübergängen
aufgefahren und faden versucht diese
besitz zu nehmen an den steirischen
grenzraum nur im fall von konrad koch
tatsächlich gelungen ist das kardinal
landesteilen sloweniens damals bereits
kämpfe zwischen der slowenischen
territorialverteidigung und der jva
ich war damals in der steiermark
beteiligt eben an der
einsatzvorbereitung einsatzplanung
führung von einsätzen in der steiermark
defence-bereich 35 heute wohl auch als
zeitzeuge aufgefordert etwas dazu zu
sagen ein zeitzeuge habe ich mich
gebildet im wikipedia sie ist dass eine
person die von bestimmten historischen
ereignissen
zeugnis geben kann weil sie zu der
betreffenden zeit gelebt hat ich möchte
dazu fügen
er kann auch oder sie kann auch diesen
persönlichen eindruck wiedergeben weil
sie auch tatsächlich bei diesen
ereignissen beteiligt war
am vierten meinungs und 80 starb der
jugoslawischen staatschefs josip broz
tito ich war damals 24-jährigen leuten
und in der kasernenstraße quandt eines
schweren aus company und ich kannte grob
die jugoslawische geschichte ich habe
damals sofort gedacht hoffentlich gibt
es keinen krieg
wenige wochen später habe ich dann eine
erste nachrichtendienstliche
informationen gelesen in der über die
möglichen auswirkungen des todes von
tieto eben überlegungen angestellt waren
eine der optionen war tatsächlich das
gewaltsame auseinanderbrechen
jugoslawiens etwa in zehn jahren wo sie
beurteilt also rund um 1990 erhält man
habe in westeuropa bald auch in
österreich nach dem abzug der
sowjetischen vorfeld armeen aus den
ehemaligen osteuropäischen ländern und
aus dem fall des eisernen vorhangs und
der berliner mauer
entsprechend von der friedensdividende
gesprochen hat und gemeint hat nun haben
wir sie jetzt ewigen frieden sind die
spannungen in jugoslawien sehr rasch zum
vorschein gekommen und sichtbar geworden
und werden sie alle erinnern an die
brandrede von slobodan milosevic den
damaligen serbischen präsidenten am 28
juni 1989 aus anlass des 600
jahrestages der schlacht am amselfeld
das mit der steiermark erhielt im
frühjahr 1989 vom damals vorgesetzten
konkurrenz den auftrag einsatzplanungen
einsatz vorbereitungen einzuleiten
können sodann operationsfeld jugoslawien
in vier varianten erste variante war ein
variante im assistenzeinsatz für die
zuständigen sie wiesen
grenzschutzbehörden mit dem gerade
verfügbaren präsenten kräften etwa 1000
soldaten wäre das gewesen
die zweite variante war wieder ein
assistenzeinsatz für die zivilen
behörden allerdings schauen nach einer
teil mobilmachung jener steiermark war
vorgesehen die steirische fünfte
jägerbrigade mobil zu machen und die
dritte und die vierte variante waren
varianten für eine sehr hohe bedrohung
hier wäre es notwendig gewesen
erhebliche teile der steirischen miliz
mobil zu machen
um dieser bedrohung entgegen zu treten
also meine sicherer sein als an der
staatsgrenze in dieser variante 3 und 4
abzuwickeln
wie gesagt bei der heizung 2 war gedacht
und geplant als assistenzeinsatz für die
zivilen behörden
zur erinnerung damals auch heute noch
aber das ist ganz besonders war dieses
bundes eine ausbildungs armee und hätte
für einsätze mobil gemacht werden sollen
diese vier einsatzwagen wurde in
kürzester zeit aus geplant bis ins
detail unter der korrelation der chor
kanadas 1 und gemeinsam mit dem damals
unterstellten konnten in strass feldbach
gras oder sagt michel
und auch hier ein zufall im mai 1990 gab
es die touren durch mäßige charakter des
bundesheeres auch hier in der steiermark
und da wurden diese einst als
vorbereiter und nochmals geprüft vom
damaligen kommentar und vom damaligen
ministerium und nochmals gecheckt auch
auf der zivilen seite gab es im rahmen
des clan des koalitionsausschusses auf
ebenes anders der steirischen
landesregierung intensiv einsatz
vorbereiterin geleitet und koordiniert
und damalige landesamt direktor
stellvertreter hofert drk und ordner
wurden in kürzester zeit ebenfalls
umfangreiche planungen angestellt
es wurde die einsatzpläne die
verhandelbaren im bereich des verkehrs
und transportplanung des flüchtlings
planes deshalb des planes aktualisiert
der alarm falls schuld für die
verstärkten der zur klärung der show
marie praktisch neu aufgestellt und
aktualisiert es wurden umfangreiche
assistenzeinsatz für eine deutliche
grenzmarkierung vorbereitet personell
und materiell das material inklusive
absprachen über die koordination und
kommunikation zwischen militär
bundesheer und den zivilen behörden in
einen allfälligen anlassfall und nicht
nur das es gab auch ein konkretes
planspiel 1 nv planspielen im juli 1990
und der feuerwehr und zivilschutz ruhe
bringen und diese r planungen ebenfalls
zumindest einmal auf dem papier auf
tauglichkeit zu überprüfen
russland.ru amazon alte straße hat eine
ähnliche aktivität mit den grands
bezirkshauptmannschaften nochmals an
auch in der kasernenstraße durchgeführt
ich bin absolut sicher dass diese
intensiven einsatzvorbereitung im rahmen
der kollidierten führung der usv einen
ganz wesentlichen beitrag geleistet
haben so den erfolgreichen abwicklung
dieses dann folge und wenig später
folgenden einsatzes bevor ich jetzt nun
auf ein paar wenige besondere lage
entwicklungen eingehen möchte ist aber
notwendig doch gewiss eine gewisse
politische zustände zu den damen
zeitpunkt in erinnerung zu rufen und
auch wird das bundesheer damals
sozusagen
damals ging wie gesagt die sowjetischen
vorfeld armee waren abgezogen
der eiserne vorhang durchschnitten
deutschland wieder vereinigen die mauer
in berlin gefallen
es gab aber auch krieg im nahen osten am
15 jänner 199 begann die operation
desert storm zur befreiung von kuwait
nachdem kuwait die mich august 90 vom
irakischen diktator saddam hussein
überfallen wurde
am 15 193 hätte eigentlich touren und
mäßig die jugoslawische präsidentschaft
an den kroaten diebe message übergehen
sollen
die spannungen zwischen den slawischen
teilrepubliken haben das nicht mehr
zugelassen
das wurde blockiert und so da haben die
dinge eher lauf um das bundesheer das
bundesheer befand sich zusammen haben
zeit und initiativen sinnkrise es wurde
die friedensdividende eingefordert
politischen schlagworte hießen vier
monate sind genug um es sehr leid die
kronenzeitung schlagzeile weg mit diesem
bundesheer die ungeliebten traten
abfangjäger waren in dieser steiermark
gelandet seit september rund 90 befand
sie aber auch dieses bundesheer mit rund
2000 soldaten des präsents standen uns
als trends einsatz zur überwachung der
österreichisch-ungarische staatsgrenze
zur verhinderung der illegalen migration
der letzten juniwoche stand in der
kasernenstraße radkersburg feldbach und
fehring rund 500 rekruten junge männer
trompeten aus dem einzugstermin jänner
voll ausgebildet knapp vor der abrüsten
und 300 junge männer knapp über hendrik
genau diesen kasernen und durch zufall
gab es auch eine werbung der miliz das
sperma der und 543 hat damals geübt die
pionierkompanie dieses partei uns befand
sich seit dem 26 juni in katastrophen
assistenzeinsatz gesang kathrein am
hauenstein am 27 juni also einen tag
nach dem unabhängigkeits feierlichkeiten
brachen die kämpfe eben aus zwischen
slowenien und rational verteidigung und
der jva und da konnte der lage
eskalation wurde das programm athens
schreiben die alarmierung der
vorbereiteten assistenzkräfte
angeordneten und befohlen
für die variante eins des
operationssaals jugoslawien
wie wir erwartet haben und es wurde eine
führungs bereitschaft angeordnet für
alle gemeinden und den ställen und
truppen im bereich 5 zu unserer
überraschung kann keine assistenz
anforderung für diese vorbereitungen ein
zufall aber allerdings hörten wir dass
die steirische lagerung in wien ein
gesucht hat und bereitstellung
assistenzkräfte über das vorbereitete
ausmaß hinaus und am abend des 27
haben auch die erste alarmmeldung aus
strass dass hubschrauber der
jugoslawischen volksarmee der luft
landung in buchenberg hier drehe
durchgeführt haben offenbar wurden
kräfte angewendet um einen angriff
vorzubereiten auf die slowenische der
verteidigung die die parole spielfeld
denn die besatzung jugoslawischer
soldaten sich befand umstellt hat um
diese nominierung soldaten anzugreifen
trotz mehrfacher warnungen über wenigen
stunden bevorstehende kämpfe und um
diesen grenzübergang und die
grenzübergänge
insgesamt gab es keinen einsatzbefehl an
die bereitgestellt kräfte an die
alarmierten kräfte
vielmehr habe es zu meiner völligen
überraschung waren einsatz des
bundesheeres an der staatsgrenze nur
deshalb weil befürchtet wurde dass die
muslimische volk sammelt diesen einsatz
des bundesheeres als vorwand benutzen
könnte und die grenzübergänge
anzugreifen oder vielleicht sogar auf
österreichisches staatsgebiet die
kampfhandlungen fortzusetzen
und am 28 juni um 09 45 uhr las man im
teletext einer aussendung der
österreichischen bundesregierung in der
so lesen war es sei alles zu unterlassen
was nach provokation aussieht eigene
panzer an der staatsgrenze wären das
falsche signal
ich muss ehrlich gestehen
dass ich zu diesen zeitpunkt im gehorsam
über den primat der politik ohnmächtigen
zorn empfand schließlich haben wir
soldaten gelobt der republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und mit der
waffe zu verteidigen
und wozu dann all diese vorbereitungen
den monaten davor dass intensiven
absprachen wenn es nunmehr plötzlich
politisch nicht mehr opportun war diesen
einsatz durchzuführen entschlossen es zu
warten nannte der historie der manfried
rauchensteiner in einer publikation aus
dem jahr 2011
dieses verhalten der österreichischen
bundesregierung und so mancher vertreter
nach dem anschlag eine assistenz
anforderung gab es keinen einsatzbefehl
gab musste daher die staatsgrenze an der
wie ein esel markiert werden ad hoc
wurde entschieden dass das beamten zur
wache die waren ohnehin vorgestellt wie
man ortskundig und bedienstete der
straßenverwaltung zu tun hätten
allerdings kaum hatten sie begonnen ist
dass der 11 uhr tatsächlich am 28 juni
zum vollen ausbruch der kämpfe um diesen
grenzübergang die kanäle spielfeld und
die grenzen spiel fand und um alle
grenzübergänge und kleinste über den
stellen an der staatsgrenze gekommen
wie gesagt auch unter 1 als
jugoslawischer jagdbomber die hier lkw
blogger südlich von shanti mit luft
boden raketen angegriffen haben ein
unglaubliches schauspiel und in
radkersburg ist eine gepanzerte einheit
der jva durchgebrochen bis zum
grenzübergang wurde aber dann von der
slowenischen territorialverteidigung
umstellt und abgeschnitten
im selben zeitpunkt gab es anonyme
warnungen über den bevorstehenden
angriff mit chemischen waffen auf den
raum handy es gab anonyme warnung über
einen luftangriff jugoslawischen
luftangriff auf das akw krsko und sie
kann sich gut vorstellen welche gefühle
das bei uns ausgelöst hat die grants
bevölkerung weil wir die und
die kite des bundesheeres aufgebracht
und bietet bei spenden kurz kassieren
aber jetzt wo man euch brauchen
versteckt sich in der kaserne
das war einer der mehrfach gehörten
vorwürfe endlich am nachmittag gab es
dann vom chor kommen 1 die genehmigung
einer ersten demonstrationsfahrt mit jag
panzer aus der kaserne über jahren
hausen nach bis bald und um 17 uhr dann
die genehmigung die vorbereiteten
assistenzkräfte in den grenzraum zu
verlegen
immer noch rechneten wir hier der
steiermark und natürlich auch vorne an
der staatsgrenze mit der nunmehr anlaufe
das ist denkt einsatz für die
zivilbehörden der in zeitpunkt
allerdings hat der minister fasslabend
in wien bereits entschieden einen
militärischen einsatz nach literat des
wer gesetzes anzuordnen
wir wussten das zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
nicht und den erlangten auf skurrile
weise kenntnis von diesen neuen
rechtsgrundlage diese einsatz verfügung
immerhin ein militärschlag ist das
dokument gedanken über fax an das amt
der steiermärkischen us-regierung der
nation von dort weiter in die kleinst
bezirkshauptmannschaften und von dort in
die kasernenstraße drosseln konnte kann
hat das dokument damit gebracht zu einer
befehlsausgabe 1 will kann man der
steiermark und hat das dokument den
herren damaligen wieder karten zwischen
dem brenner acrobat ableckt übergeben
ein gravierendes problem am 28 juni war
aber auch das unmittelbar bevor stellte
abrüsten dieser soldaten aus den eiligen
stream in jena voll ausgebildet und
hätten sie dringend gebraucht
es war aber auch die milizsoldaten das
sperma der 543 auch die voll ausgebildet
sie hätten wir auch dringend gebraucht
dieser aufschub der entlastung der
reserve wurde abgelehnt
mit dem neuling hindernis das wäre eine
provokation für jugoslawien für die jva
und im fall der miliz wurde er das
juristische problem bemühen
das arbeitsgericht ist schon ist richtig
war
es ist nicht möglich den erlassen übung
direkt in einen militärischen einsatz
überzutreten ich habe im jahr 2011 von
einem sehr hoch reisezeit zeugen aus wie
nach dem bfv einen
hintergrundinformationen bekommen über
die damaligen entscheidung vorgänger
entgehen
ich habe das gelesen aber bis heute kann
ich es nicht verstehen und nicht
nachvollziehen warum das abgelehnt wurde
denn wir hätten diesen soldaten wirklich
dringend gebraucht und die mussten dann
mancherorts mit soldaten in den einsatz
gehen die haben beginn des vierten
ausbilder sports standen wir haben
natürlich als berücksichtigt es gab
einen sehr hohen kakaoanteil und diese
soldaten wurde auch abseits der
erkennbaren brennpunkten eingesetzt
dennoch es war ein sehr hohes risiko und
die gefährlichste lage er gab sich aus
meiner sicht damals schon und auch heute
immer noch wie ein kleines rückgang
radkersburg durch die dort
eingeschlossenen gebannte der einheit
der jugoslawischen volksarmee
dort gab es einen vertreter einer
freiwilligen des eröffnungstermins
oktober 1990 dem zehnten aus monat
befindlich geführt von fit und gustav
beyer erst heute hier und er wurde
unterstützt von einer jagd banzer zog
von leutnant mix aus der belgier kaserne
und diese soldaten haben diesen grenzen
gegangen massiv zur verteidigung
vorbereitet am 30 juni 91 sonntag kam
dann der vorwurf aus jugoslawien das
österreichische bundesheer über die
slowenischen territorialverteidigung bei
der einschließung der kräfte der jva am
grenzübergang spielfeld und radkersburg
unterstützen
dieser im sommer die staatsgrenzen so
verläuft wie sie verläuft
das wurde natürlich sofort vom brunnen
minister fastabend zurückgewiesen und
die mit der attachés in österreich
akkreditiert waren auch der islamische
wurden am ersten juli
konkret fordert den griff der einsatz
eingewiesen wenn gerade keine
alarmzeichen
das wurde da sich die alarmierung
ausgelöst für die vorbereitung eine
mobilmachung erreichte die spannung
einen weiteren höhepunkt ich bin aber
heute noch überzeugt felsenfest
überzeugt dass die intensiven
vorbereitungen zur verteidigung des
grenzüberganges radkersburg profis und
bayern mit seinem mannen eine
tatsächliche reale beurteilung des
kommandanten der jva einheit in borat
bonner kontaktiert hat nämlich einfach
in den frühen morgenstunden das zweite
juli unser begehung einer schweren
grenzverletzungen einfach für die
radkersburger brücke zu rasseln vorbei
beim lkh radkersburg hinunter nach
sicher drauf und wieder auf islamische
staatsgebiet wenn man sich das anschaut
mit hohem einsatz tempo und ohne
widerstand eine einheit von etwa einer
stunde und wir hätten aus belgrad
folgendes gehört wir haben das nicht
angeordnet
das war eine aktion der verzweiflung der
eingeschlossenen konnten diese
gepanzerten einheit die aufgefordert
wurde sich zu ergeben alle was macht zu
geben und abzuziehen
ich bin überzeugt wird sondern bei und
leute und mit ihren soldaten haben
diesen schwerwiegenden vorfall
verhindert indem sie diese vorbereitung
getroffen haben und dass diese
erkennbaren vorbereitung waren ja
entsprechend den jugoslawischen attaché
auch bekannt schließlich und zwei juli
flammten nochmals die kein frevel auf
rund um die grenzübergänge spielfeld die
kanäle wurde mit gebeutelten
kampfpanzern durch die slowenische dpa
lby zerschossen besatzung wurden zum
ausweichen aus dem gebäude gezwungen und
hier am glasberg einer schnell bezogene
regel stellung durch soldaten aus der
straßencafé übertritt auf
österreichisches staatsgebiet gehindert
und der murbrücke jeden spielfeld haben
sich 16 soldaten der jva freiwillig
ergeben den abgas burg gerieten
zahlreiche gebäude ein
auch der kirchturm hauptmann mittermeier
command eines hubschrauber schwarm wird
die sind aber auch nicht vergessen denn
er hatte den auftrag bis dato einzigen
panzer abwehr lenkwaffen sucht des
bundesheeres das ist damals gab und
japan 21 aus tirol von dakar bis kaserne
rechtsmäßig in radkersburg am sportplatz
an zu landen um die verteidigung dort zu
verstärken
am 3 juli schließlich übernahm das amt
der stadt die mit zwei wenn es das
feldbach die volle führungsverantwortung
den ostteil der sicherung sprecher
sascha den österreicher steiermark oder
ein programm führt der unverändert
spielfeld und sanften kräfte im westen
der mur als rückhalt für die kräfte in
der schusslinie und durch chor kann man
da einst dann noch eine sehr schwer
gepanzerte kampfgruppe zugeführt die
kampfgruppe in hand nach dem know how
mit den komponenten bestehen dass
kampfpanzern und artillerie weiteren
jagd panzern pionieren
ein verfügungsrahmen leibnitz diese ganz
gruppe hat dann auch einsätze richtung
radkersburg vor geübt die lage hat sich
aber wieder beruhigt zum achten juli
wurde das abkommen von prionen
unterzeichnet und das begann der abzug
der jva aus rumänien am 31 juli 91 wurde
dann der hand der einsatz des
bundesheeres offiziell beendet dieser
einsatz hatte natürlich gravierende
auswirkungen auf das bundesheer selbst
beispielhaft möchte ich erwähnen die
präsenz das des präsidenten mobil
warnsystem wurde krank regeln geändert
die mobilmachungsstärke wurde gravierend
verringert die bewaffnung mit bands art
während flüge ab der lenkwaffen war
plötzlich unumstritten
die empfehlung eingeforderten tragen
abfangjäger und der bewaffnung mit luft
luft raketen zeit weiter bei ebenfalls
plötzlich unumstritten denn es ist ihnen
gelungen luftraumverletzungen weitere
luftraumverletzungen
in flugzeuge zu verhindern in
straßenbahn sind der transportfahrzeug
band uhr erfunden und eingeführt um also
der planwagen infanterie auf 680 endlich
ein ende zu bereiten und das mit der
befugnis geschätzt wo die auf schiene
gesetzt um für zukünftige einsätze
verbessere die rahmenbedingungen zu
haben
allen beteiligten wurde gedankt einsatz
medaillen wurden verteilt
dieser gedenkstein wurde aufgestellt und
eingeweiht
das geschehen wissenschaftlich
abgearbeitet und publiziert was sie mich
denn auch zum abschluss viele personen
gruppen nochmals erwähnen und man ist
der doktor werner fasslabend und seinen
beraterstab imperial frauen wie er hatte
den mut in dieser lage einen
militärischen einsatz anzuordnen
stellvertretend für alle eingesetzten
offiziere oberland heute bringt er in
ruhe
josef bauer politikern stellvertretend
für alle eingesetzten unter bisher viel
zeit in ruhe gustav beyer
stellvertretend für alle eingesetzten
zivilbedienstete frau gut und lang
geschah in der vermittlung unter
kasernenstraße und stellvertretend für
unsere grundwehrdiener corp ifc opéra
mustermann und wehrmann mustermann die
alle unmittelbaren der staatsgrenze in
der sichtlinie eingesetzt werden
ein besonderer dank gilt wohl auch heute
doch herr hofer tochter gehört ordner
erstellen sondern langsam trägt er
stellvertretend für alle am einsatz
beteiligten zivilen behörden und
einsatzorganisationen in diesen
kombinierten einsatz mit uns erfolgreich
abgewickelt haben und ebenfalls ist das
vierte gruppe der grenz bevölkerung die
jungs fantastisch bei diesem einsatz
unterstützt hat ihnen allen gebührt der
dank der republik österreich
der dank der heimat präsidien dieser
krisenlage einen beitrag geleistet haben
zum schutz unserer heimat denn mit ihnen
gemeinsam haben wir diesen einsatz
durchaus mit
das gerade keine echten gefechte gott
sei dank mit der jva keine verwandten
keine gefallen war wunderbares wetter
es gab keine unfälle es gab keine schieß
und spreng unfälle war schon auch glück
dabei aber das glück des tüchtigen denn
wir waren sehr gut vorbereitet und
deswegen ist es gelungen diesen einsatz
positiv zum abschluss zu bringen
ganz zum schluss trotz der ernsten
situation möchte ich auch eine heitere
situation noch kurz schildern hat man
die aus eisenbach als berufsoffizier in
der kasernenstraße war
verbindungsoffizieren zur
bezirkshauptmannschaft deutschlandsberg
und die dortige bezirkshauptmannschaft
zu unterstützen und mit ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten bei diesem einsatz
bedienstete der straßenverwaltung
treffen irgendwo auf der bundesstraße
abbas bundesstraße einen trupp soldaten
und fragen diesen receiver eisenbach ist
und dass soldaten schon geantwortet
haben keine ahnung misshandelt foto und
konnte nur mit danke
wir setzen fort mit dem militär
geistlichen teil mit dem ökumenischen
friedensgebet und zur einstimmung hören
wir den choral pax vobis com friede sei
mit euch
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin
geschätzter herr landeshauptmann werte
ehrengäste und kameraden
ja ich bin einer jener soldaten des
damaligen speer bataillons 543 das sah
einen tag vor 30 jahren genau wieder ins
leben entlassen wurde
noch während der übung waren wir alle
der meinung dass wir einen einsatz gehen
würden den essenszeiten im speisesaal am
truppenübungsplatz seetaler glaube es
mucksmäuschenstill weil wir die
entwicklungen am fernseher verfolgten
meine milizsoldaten ich war damals zugs
kommunen die rasierten sich erlangen
rauschebärte habt damit die schutzmaske
besser passt und noch lange nach
dienstschluss übten sie regelmäßig die
handhabung ihrer waffen war wie es
hingehört es kann man doch anders unser
damaliger militärpfarrer steiermark
jever mollner während der
sicherungseinsatz es hier an der grenze
im einsatz
und damals wie heute war es eine
wichtigste frage wie geht's dir
und damals wie heute waren seine
wichtigsten sinnesorgane seine beiden
ohren im viel gesprächen war es aber
auch die zeit des gemeinsamen gebets für
die eigene unversehrtheit und die der
kameraden für die familien zu hause und
natürlich auch für den frieden und ein
bisschen frieden wollen wir heute
gemeinsam beten
damals wie heute gilt die weisheit der
menschen die sich im leben und im laufe
der geschichte immer wieder bewahrheitet
und bestätigt der friede beginnt im
eigenen haus und auch die umkehrung ist
manchmal bittere realität denn auch der
krieg beginnt im eigenen haus vorteil
feindseligkeit abneigung entwachsen
immer wieder auch der kleinen und
konkreten lebenswelt drinnen menschen
voneinander zerstören nachbarschaft und
freundschaft gleichen unsichtbaren
zäunen und mauern inmitten von
straßenzügen dörfern und städten
das heutige gedenken hier an der
südlichen stadtgrenze österreichs ruft
in erinnerung dass es sich im kleinen
lohnt dem frieden zu dienen sich in wort
und tat für versöhnung das miteinander
von menschen einzusetzen und brücken zu
bauen zwischen milieus und vorteilen
wenn es in einer pluralen gesellschaft
gelingt in vielen kleinen
lebensgemeinschaften friedlich zu leben
kann der freedom großen ein stück mehr
realität werden
das bleibt immer geschenkt in einem
anderen wort unserer tradition gnade und
deshalb war der gemeinsame ökumenische
im geist verbunden ein gebet des
heiligen franziskus sprechen
das nichts an aktualität verloren hat
ja mach mich zu einem werkzeug deines
friedens dass ich liebe wo man hasst das
ich verzeihe wo man beleidigt dass ich
verbinde wo streit ist dass ich die
wahrheit sage
wo irrtum ist dass sich glauben und
vertrauen bringen wo zweifel droht dass
sich hoffnung weg wo verzweiflung wählt
das ist licht entzündet
wo finsternis regiert dass ich freude
bringe oder kummer gewohnt herr gib mir
das bemühen nicht dass ich getröstet
werden sondern dass ich tröste nicht
dass ich zuerst verstanden werde sondern
versuchen den anderen zu verstehen nicht
dass ich geliebt werde sondern dass ich
zuerst liebe denn wer sich hingibt der
empfängt der sich selbst vergisst der
findet derzeit den wird verziehen
und wer stirbt der wacht zum ewigen
leben armer mann
viele kameraden von der evangelischen
und katholischen militärplaner
militärplaner manfred balkan und militär
kaplan johannes freitag ich danke recht
herzlich für euren beitrag des
ökumenischen friedensgebet wir hören nun
die steiermark fanfare und traditionell
wann immer wieder in der steiermark die
steiermark fanfare höheren kündigt sie
die ansprache die grußbotschaft denn
willkommensgruß und das sehr geschätzten
steirischen landeshauptmannes keine
schützenhöfer
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr landeshauptmann
hermann schützenhöfer seit nunmehr 2015
kann ich mich erinnern sie bei
unzähligen veranstaltungen wirklich als
wahren freund des österreichischen
bundesheeres und der steirischen
einsatzorganisationen kennengelernt zu
haben seien sie uns herzlich willkommen
ich bitte um ihre ansprache ja nachdem
ich ein wahrer freund des bundesheers
bin lasse ich das manuskript im sack und
versuche es kurz zu machen liebe frau
bundesministerin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren als angehöriger meiner
generation ist man eigentlich ein
glückskind
ich bin im 70 lebensjahr ich habe nicht
wie meine eltern und großeltern not und
krieger lebt ich habe nie hungern nicht
frieren müssen
im gegenteil ich habe miterlebt ich war
gerade lehrling wie 1968 die warschauer
truppen die truppen des warschauer pakts
in prag einmarschiert sind um den prager
frühling wieder zu brechen
ich habe miterlebt wie in warschau in
fragen budapest auch in bukarest
menschen unter einsatz ihres lebens um
die freiheit und um die demokratie
gekämpft haben seien 68 erleben wird das
78 ist johannes paul der zweite papst
geworden ich komme aus einem fernen land
hat er gesagt anlässlich seiner wahl und
dem ostblock war es das wert dass man
diesen papst umbringen wollte ich
behaupte heute noch
der sohn helmut kohl der sonne michael
gorbatschow das ohne papst johannes bald
in zweiter und ohne ronald regen
der kommunismus in europa nicht oder
damals noch nicht gebrochen hätte werden
können
1980 ist jugoslawien zerbrochenen krieg
der in der ausformung eine million tote
gekostet hat 1985 kam gorbatschow
gorbatschow und helmut kohl
das waren die architekten dies ist neu
in europa und im mai 89 waren es die
ungarn die ihre staffel drehte und seine
niedergerissen und den mint haben und es
waren die deutschen im november 89
die die innerdeutsche grenze überwunden
haben durch den fall der mauer und damit
war der durchbruch geschafft
1991 war ja im ehemaligen jugoslawien
schon der krieg da und dort im gange und
am 25 juni haben sich slowenien und
kroatien unabhängig erklärt und die
jugoslawische volksarmee wollte das
nicht wahrhaben
alois mock niemand sonst als alois
folgte außenminister hat damals hinter
den kulissen schon seinen guten freund
helmut kohl gebeten rasch einzuschreiten
in europa war sich ja völlig uneinig und
so ist es am 8 juli schon zum brioni
abkommen gekommen da waffenstillstand
das war ein erster großer erfolg
und im dezember 91 am 16 dezember hat es
ein ministertreffen ein
außenministertreffen deg der
europäischen gemeinschaft österreich war
damals ja noch nicht dabei in brüssel
gegeben mit der frage wie tun wir mit
der anerkennung weitern alois mock als
außenminister österreichs was trägt
dafür und hat helmut kohl händeringend
gebeten diese staaten anzuerkennen nur
dann wird ruhe sein nur dann wird
frieden einkehren
der österreichische bundeskanzler franz
vranitzky war strikt dagegen
das ist die schlichte wahrheit und hat
den außenminister korrigiert
großbritannien weiter gegen frankreich
war dagegen die usa sowieso die meisten
eu-staaten waren dagegen
aber helmut kohl hat dafür gesorgt dass
die außenminister hat auch frankreich
ins boot geholt da hat es ja diese achse
noch gegeben einstimmig beschlossen
haben slowenien und kroatien
anzuerkennen der mitte jänner des
nächsten jahres und dann hat halt auch
österreich mitgemacht und damit war die
friedens grundlage gelegt
das möchte ich ganz besonders betonen
weil ohne diese politische klarheit
alois mock ist in kroatien ein
säulenheiliger heute noch wenn man
hinkommen wäre dass alle sehr sehr viel
schwieriger geworden
zweiter punkt ich danke dem bundesheer
ich bin so stolz als landeshauptmann bin
fast bei jeder angelobung feiert dabei
wie auch bei den aus musterungen der
polizei weil ich jenen menschen die ihr
eigenes leben notfalls riskieren dankbar
bin dafür dass sie die menschen im lande
dass sie ihr land gemäß dem treueschwur
auch verteidigen das sagt man in
heutigen zeit ja kam er aber es ist so
und das bleibt so
und das wirst du generell gesagt hat
stimmt aber seit wird die amokfahrt die
flüchtlingskrise und vor 30 jahren hier
erlebt haben was möglich ist von heute
auf morgen ist das ansehen des
bundesheers der polizei gewachsen und
alles was wir tun können werden wir tun
um das auch in zukunft zu steigern und
der dritte und letzte punkt wir gerade
gestern im orf mit vertretern der eu und
so weiter eine debatte gehabt zur
zukunft europas
wer freunde da stehen nicht die band hat
ist kommunismus
da können wir drüber fahren ohne dass
uns wer fragt wo wir hinwollen wenn
nicht gerade epidemie
das hätten sich unsere väter und mütter
nicht zu träumen gewagt mein vater 87
verstorben hat sich immer vor dem
einmarsch der kommunisten geführt hätte
nie geglaubt dass es 89 eigentlich so
weit ist dieses europa kennt keine
grenzen mehr dieses europa muss aber
jetzt auch zeigen abseits von
irgendwelchen streits in bezug auf die
migration oder die impfstoffe dass es
nicht nur ein europa des sozialen und
der wirtschaft sondern auch ein friedens
europa ist denn nur durch einen geeinten
europa werden wir es schaffen dass es
weiterhin in diesem raum keinen krieg
gibt all überall sonst in der welt haben
wir ohnehin viel zu viel und will und
unruhe und daher ist es gut wenn staaten
die sich momentan mit bestimmten formen
der demokratie und so weiter und der
meinungsfreiheit in ihren ländern schwer
tun wenn die drinnen sind in der
europäischen union und nicht draußen
denn nur in einer gemeinschaft kann man
probleme und es gibt probleme auch lösen
und daher möchte ich insgesamt sagen
redet man um den brei herum
schauen wir uns an was ist im westbalkan
gibt schauen wir nicht so wie der ganze
staaten von anderen staaten in der form
besetzt werden dass aufgekauft wird
versuchen wir diese staaten zu uns zu
nehmen mit all den problemen die sie
haben ja auch wir haben uns ja einmal
entwickeln müssen
und ganz zuletzt readsoft mit
schulklassen für gymnasiasten für
ministranten für volksschüler ist der
krieg täglich im fernsehen aber weit weg
der jugend klar zu machen dass friede
freiheit wohlstand nicht gepachtet sind
sondern dass man sich das tägliche
arbeiten muss das halte ich für eine der
hauptaufgaben in diesem europa das in
manchen fragen ein bisschen saturiert
geworden ist aber ein europa das in
seiner größe in seiner stärke auch als
kontinent alternativlos ist und bleibt
und deshalb ist dieser heute gedanken
ein dank auch an den allmächtigen ein
dank an die soldatinnen und soldaten
polizistinnen und polizisten an die
zivilbevölkerung die uns in all den
jahren geholfen hat aber auch ein tag
der freude weil es in unseren händen
link europa gut weiter zu bauen
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank herr landeshauptmann
erstellung und dem amt unserer frau
bundesministerin entsprechend höheren
wir zur ankündigung ihrer festansprache
die festen fest fanfare vorgetragen von
der militärmusik steiermark
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hoch geschätzte frau bundesministerin
stationäre festansprache bieten hohe
geistlichkeit sehr geehrter herr
landeshauptmann herr generalleutnant der
militärkommandant der
landespolizeidirektor generalmajor
vertreter der polizei bezirkshauptmann
im dienst um die neue sehr geehrte ehren
und festgäste vor allem aber verkehrte
soldaten sind wie es ihnen gegangen ist
als die abfangjäger über uns drüber
clubs an
wir haben applaudiert ich weiß nicht wie
es denjenigen gegangen ist
die das kampfflugzeug nicht erkannt
haben
aber dabei so wie es mir heute ein
soldat gesagt hat ein sehr mulmiges
gefühl hatten
zeitzeugen sind auch diejenigen die aus
der eigenen erfahrung sowie der
generalmajor gemacht hat berichten und
erzählen können
ich bin das nicht ich entstamme der
generation die frieden freiheit
sicherheit kennt herr bürgermeister
abgeordnete
es gilt am heutigen tag denjenigen danke
zu sagen wie im einsatz
es gilt am heutigen tag auch denjenigen
zu danken die im einsatz sind
damals wie heute
wir schützen österreich damals 7700
soldaten die im einsatz waren
und auch wenn man keinen direkten
vergleich mit vor 30 jahren ziehen darf
und soll dann sei an dieser stelle auch
denjenigen danke gesagt am höchsten
punkt der pandemie 8000 soldatinnen wie
gibt es mittlerweile im unterschied zu
vor 30 jahren und soldaten die im inland
und im ausland ihren einsatz versehen
das mit einer unglaublichen
einsatzbereitschaft juni travel damals
spürbar war und die auch jetzt spürbar
ist und wenn der landeshauptmann
angesprochen hat die situation am
westbalkan ja wohl auch da sind unsere
soldaten und soldatinnen im einsatz in
einer wichtigen friedenserhaltenden
missionen ich konnte mich letzte woche
davon überzeugen ein dankeschön an sie
alle ein dankeschön aber auch
rückblickend nach den 30 jahren an
diejenigen die die verantwortung tragen
mussten
der landesebene verteidigungsminister
wurde schon angesprochen einmal
diejenigen die in der zusammenarbeit
auch zwischen den verwaltungsbehörden
der polizei den soldaten auch dem zoll
der auch heute erwähnt worden ist post
und nicht zu vergessen auch die
öbb wo man gesehen hat dem miteinander
sind auch schwierigste einsätze
bewältigt auch wenn man nicht
vergleichen soll man kann entschlossen
zu warten oder man muss das eine oder
andere mal entschlossen auch handeln und
ich sage ganz offen ich hätte mir nicht
gedacht dass ich eine einsatz verfügung
unterschreiben musste die erstmalige
aufbietung der miliz bedeutet ich habe
auch nicht geglaubt dass sich über 2000
grund wird ihnen die märz vergangenen
jahres abgerüstet hätten in die augen
schauen musste und sie zwei monate
länger verpflichtet werden mussten damit
wir alle einsätze alle anforderungen
erfüllen konnten und können
ein dankeschön an die soldatinnen und
soldaten ein dankeschön an dieser stelle
an alle die es im miteinander bewältigt
haben und ein danke schön herr
landeshauptmann auch an dich der du
immer ein unterstützer des
österreichischen bundesheeres warst und
bist es lebe das österreichische
bundesheer es lebe die republik
österreich
[Applaus]
unser aller respekt vor der dank frau
bundesministerin für ihre bedenklichen
worte wir hören nun unmittelbar vor ende
des heutigen festtages die steirische
landesgruppe handel
danach wird der kommandant ausgerückten
truppe mallorca tre cool an die frau
bundesministerin die beendigung der
veranstaltung melden und um weitere
befehle erbitten
[Musik]
[Applaus]